hello that got their attention grace hi
guys my name is grace Helbig if you
didn't know if you did know this week
I've been really busy with the grace
Helbig show my television show on E
Fridays at 10:30 following the soup you
should watch it because time gets spent
creating it I've been so busy with that
that I've been very out of the loop in
terms of pop culture and culture just
the world and the things that are
happening in it so it's just spending
some time looking at news and then I
remembered news is really chinks sad
there are awful awful things that are
happening in the world and none of us
can control all of it but I can control
myself trying to put positive energy and
happiness into the world so I thought it
would make a video today
that's simply trying to make someone
happy because at the end of the day
we're all just human beings experiencing
this shitstorm called life and trying to
make the best of it there are so many
things that are out of our control
there's just so much stuff there's so
much stuff happening and you can't all
of it I do believe that all of us
deserve to be happy I think that is
vacuuming right so I do believe it is
part of our responsibility as humans to
when we can try to make others happy if
we are not after yourself someone
recently told me that the greatest piece
of advice they got was even on
worse day try to make it a good day for
someone else and I thought that was such
a great philosophy because there's too
much that happens to not at least speed
this shuttle my exercise is probably not
if you're feeling alone you are not
alone if you're feeling sad it's okay
make it better
if you're feeling mad things get better
if you are feeling depressed it's okay
things get better and you're just trying
to make you feel good you deserve to
feel good we all deserved a really good
good and we all only live once so there
you go there was my attempt to try and
make you guys happy and to remind you
that you deserve it I don't know this
might be the dumbest video I've ever
made and I'm very okay with that the
grace Helbig show Fridays at 10:30
following visit I'm sorry it's just
something got stuck in my throat Oh got
it it was a plug plug that stuck in my
throat